- We have to figure out where
it is exactly ourselves.
Good morning, I hope you're
having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens.
I'm in Gilgit-Baltistan in Pakistan
in the mountains, and
starting this morning
from a very strategic, a very
important place in the world.
The plan for today is
we're driving from Gilgit
to Hunza Valley, and Hunza Valley is known
for being one of the most
spectacularly beautiful
places in Pakistan,
and maybe in the world.
And the food people eat,
people are known to have
a very, very long life, some
of the longest lifespans
in the world because the food is so good.
The food is so fresh, and the air
and water quality is so good,
and definitely tonight for
dinner is gonna be a highlight
because we've been invited to a local home
to experience the longevity
food of Hunza Valley.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
This is the merger of three of the world's
highest mountain chains,
so let me stand up,
let me see if I can get this right.
But directly behind me right here
that's where the Himalayas,
I guess, the Himalayas begin.
That's where they collided.
So, the Himalayas are there.
If you look behind me,
what's up Ali and Gill?
- Hey, we're good.
(laughing)
- This is the Hindu Kush mountain range,
and then if you look over on this side
where you have these jagged rock peaks,
that's the Karakoram mountain range,
and then the river is the confluence
between the Gilgit and the Indus rivers.
That is the actual point where all three
of the mountain chains collide.
This is just a quiet, peaceful,
all you can hear literally
is the rivers flowing.
(footsteps crunching)
Just for a little more context,
the Himalayas are of course home to
the highest mountain in
the world, Mount Everest.
The Karakorum mountain range
is home to K2, but sometimes
they're referred to kind of as
the same, but, geologically,
the Karakorams are a
total different range,
and then the Hindu Kush is actually
right behind me right now.
(inspiring electronic music)
And then back at the hotel for breakfast.
Nothing like curry for
breakfast in the morning.
This one is called chicken Achari.
It has like a mustardy taste to it.
Some keema, some minced meat curry.
(sipping)
Okay, and that completes breakfast.
We've gotta pack up our
bags and we are moving.
We're on our way to Hunza.
(fluid instrumental music)
Thank you to Gilgit Serena Hotel
for hosting us, for sponsoring our stay.
We had a wonderful stay but we
are on our way now to Hunza,
Hunza Valley, and even the drive
is going to be spectacular,
and we're gonna stop for a viewpoint.
Hopefully we have some
clear weather today.
(horn blaring)
(upbeat instrumental music)
It's just unbelievable,
spectacular scenery.
Just taking a little stretch
but, oh man, the scenery.
There's water just
gushing from the mountain.
Just majestic.
(water rushing)
(laughing)
Oh, it's so fresh.
Oh, it's so tasty.
That's such pure water.
(water rushing)
- Wow. That is cold, and awesome. Wow.
- I got a little water up the
nose but that was so worth it.
(water rushing)
(upbeat instrumental music)
(speaking foreign language)
Welcome to Chapshoro Point, and Chapshoro,
it's like a stuffed pocket of dough,
kind of like a pastry
but filled with beef.
This version is filled with beef.
He has this huge,
rounded, concave hotplate,
and then if you come over on this side,
he has the wood fire burning
which is heating that entire iron plate.
He's rolling out the dough,
and he's gonna make one
fresh for us right now.
(speaking foreign language)
(upbeat Pakistani music)
And then that goes
directly into the hotplate
which is fed by the fire.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
- He's saying that you
have to open it from here
and then you eat it.
- [Mark] Oh, so you kind of
drink the soup at the same time.
- Exactly, so you don't
take the entire bite
because then it will spill over.
- Okay.
When I was talking to them making it,
they said it was beef
but actually it's yak.
Kinda open up the pocket like this.
Oh and hey, you just kinda
like lift up the lid.
Immediately you can smell that aroma,
the onions in there, the juices,
and you can really smell
that meatiness to it.
Oh, that looks great.
You can kind of peel off a piece, I think.
Okay, I'm gonna take a
little bit of that lid,
grab some of that yak.
Oh, look how juicy that is.
Oh, that's fantastic.
The meat mixture, the
yak mixture, is awesome.
You get the crunchy onions.
You've got like the brothy juices.
There's definitely some chili
in there, some powdered chili.
Look at Ying.
Ying got another method of eating it.
(laughing)
Ying, how is the yak?
- Very good.
- Like a pocket.
And the bread, because
he kind of fire-roasts
the bread at the same time,
he put them in the fire for a little bit,
and then on to the hotplate.
Kind of slow cooks, so it's
like the bread is gummy,
but at the same time, it's
kind of crispy on the edges,
and it has that fire-roasted flavor to it.
- What a cool dish.
- Yak meat for the first time in my life.
- [Mark] Oh, that's yak
meat for the first time?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Nice.
Follow that with some chai,
or, rather, this might be doodh patti.
The perfect accompaniment beverage.
- Mm.
(laughing)
(clapping)
(upbeat Pakistani music)
- One more cup of doodh patti as we
lounge back in these chairs.
Yeah, you can taste the creaminess,
and they're also using yak milk.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
Still have the taste of Rakaposhi.
We made it to the Rakaposhi viewpoint
which is one of the highest
mountains in this region,
7,708 meters
25 thousand and 25 feet.
It's massive, and it's fully clouded over.
You can't see the top of the summit,
but you can see the base.
You can see where the snow
and the glaciers start.
Even without being able to
see it, it just has this aura.
It has this sensation, I
mean, grand-esque monstrosity.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
- Hello.
- [Driver] Hello.
- Good morning.
- [Mark] Good morning.
(speaking foreign language)
- Thank you very much.
Welcome to the Hunza Valley,
and we drove all the way to Karimabad,
which is one of the main villages,
main towns in the valley.
It's like unimaginable beauty.
You cannot even, it's almost too much
for your eyes to even see.
Just no man could even create
something of this spectacle.
- Welcome, Sir.
- Thank you very much.
The smoke is a traditional greeting.
Very aromatic, you can smell a lot of,
like, it looks like a
mixture of pine, and needles,
and herbs that are ...
It's warming and smells great.
- Welcome, Sir.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
Oh, and we've got some
of the bread and butter.
- Bread and butter, Sir.
- Oh, nice.
Grab a little piece of that.
Get the full piece of butter?
- [Man] Yes.
- A little chunk of butter there.
Oh yeah, wow.
That's rich.
- Fresh apple juice, Sir?
- Thank you very much.
I can say, without a
doubt, this is the best cup
of apple juice in the
most beautiful location
that I've ever had apple juice in my life.
There's Micah.
(laughing)
Welcome to our room.
Yeah, we're gonna need
some thick blankets here,
thick, purple blankets.
Literally, that same exact
view is right outside
on the balcony, on the patio.
We're walking up to the Baltit Fort,
which is one of the
landmarks of Hunza Valley.
It sits on top of another
little hill, just in the shadows
of the mountain, and it's spectacular.
But we're just gonna hike up
just to get a viewpoint of it.
Yeah, we are definitely not at sea level.
Oh, you can feel your heart working.
Air is thin.
We're getting to the fort up here.
Come on Micah, we're gonna make it.
Man, we're like in the
cradle of the mountain.
This is a 700-year, and
something, old fort,
but it is all made of stone,
and then you just see the wood balconies,
and then you have this
unbelievable view again.
- Just beyond adjectives.
- Gill hasn't even spoken.
- It's beyond words, man.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
(thumping on cooking board)
(speaking foreign language)
- Hunza Food Pavilion,
have a heavenly experience.
This is just a cool, little food hut
that we have stopped in.
It's just a nice looking spot,
so we're just inquiring
about some snacks here.
What is this?
- This is Chapshoro mixture.
- [Mark] Oh, that goes inside of the-
- Yeah, chicken.
- [Mark] That goes inside of the Chap-
- Chicken, coriander, mint, ginger, onion.
(speaking foreign language)
- Oh, wow, so that's apricot oil?
- [Woman] Oil, yeah.
- [Mark] Apricot oil.
- Oil, yeah.
- But right now, she's
making a Chapshoro fresh,
but this is totally different version
from what we had earlier.
This is made with chicken, and
you can see the spices in it,
and she actually fries
hers in apricot oils.
(mellow music)
That was actually the inside mixture.
We've all taken a seat here.
It's just such a cozy, little mountain-
- It's like a miniature chalet.
- [Mark] Yeah.
(laughing)
(mellow music)
- Chapshoro, cheers.
Chapshoro, boys.
- Awe.
It's like curried chicken
inside of like doughy,
fragrant, like, it has a
chapati kind of feel to it,
but then it's so fragrant
because of that oil.
- [Gill] Whoa, this is great, yeah.
- [Ali] The chicken is
beating the yak by miles.
(laughing)
- The local cottage
cheese, set this on top.
That is like cottage cheese
with organic herbs in it.
Yeah, you're gonna put
this cottage cheese,
just smother every single bite in it.
This is something you want to be eating
when you're on a mountain.
Okay, next up is the
soup that she has today
which is called Daodao,
which is that noodle,
but it's actually, I
think, like dough pieces,
but I guess that's what
a noodle is anyways.
There's some herbs in here.
Look at that soup.
Mm, oh, it has this wonderful,
unexpected sourness to it,
and then you really taste the herbs.
Like, it tastes like a mountain mint.
Those are like little gummy noodles,
but what I like is that
amazing herb taste.
(mellow music)
Thank you very much, it was amazing.
- Welcome, welcome.
- Amazing.
Yeah, when you're in Hunza Valley,
she's just down from the Baltit Fort
- The store name is Hunza Fort Pavilion,
outside.
- [Mark] Hunza Fort Pavilion.
- Yeah, Hunza Fort Pavilion.
- [Mark] What was your name again?
- Laoshizadee.
- [Mark] Laoshizadee.
Yeah, this is the spot.
Oh yeah, you can see Hunza Food Pavilion.
(van sputters)
Okay, from here, we're
driving back to the hotel,
and they've prepared a local lunch for us,
so we're gonna go have
lunch, another lunch,
and then we will proceed
onwards from there,
but then tonight is gonna be
a very special opportunity
because we've invited to a local home
to have a local Hunza food experience.
(enchanted instrumental music)
Come on, Micah.
Here's something I've never done before.
(upbeat guitar music)
(laughing)
I can't do it.
Okay, I'm gonna have to use my hand.
(apple crunching)
Awe, Mm.
It's so crisp.
It's so juicy.
Perfect, a perfect apple.
(apple crunching)
It's still attached.
(laughing)
- [Ali] Is that the copyright
book, can I also do it?
- You can do it too.
(laughing)
I'm sure anyone who grew
up around apples has done
that before, but that's a first for me.
I didn't grow up around cold
weather where they grow apples.
(apple crunching)
Thank you very much.
- Welcome to--
- Thank you.
So, we just sat down.
We're gonna have a quick lunch,
and they're gonna prepare
a local Hunza food meal
for us for lunch today at the hotel.
(speaking foreign language)
Thin layers of dough
which have then been fried
and then stuffed with that,
looks like that similar cottage
cheese which we just ate.
Almost has like a cheese
dumpling taste to it,
but it's more like layers.
Thank you very much.
(speaking foreign language)
Okay, next dish.
Oh, there's chunks of
meat in this one, nice.
Looks very familiar.
This one is good too.
It's a little less herbaceous
than the one we just had
before, but this one has
a little more meat in it.
Main course has arrived.
Two separate things, one is the lamb.
Again, the other is Harissa
which is a traditional
staple made with wheat,
looks like almost made
into a porridge-like paste.
(upbeat instrumental music)
And silent, digging into that lamb.
- If I talk a lot during eating,
I mean, there's a problem.
(laughing)
- Oh yeah.
The ginger.
But that's just like lamb roast.
Yeah, that's delicious.
I think it's just been like,
taste like it's just been boiled.
The lamb is good but I
think it would be better
with some kind of a sauce.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Oh, that's good.
You can taste kind of like
the buttery-ness of it,
but it's really creamy,
and then you can taste the
grains of wheat as well.
Final course is dessert,
and it's in this little,
looks like almost a little
pudding with some grapes
on the side, and there's
some almonds on top.
I'm gonna grab that mint leaf as well.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Kind of has like a pumpkin taste to it.
Oh, the beloved apricot oil.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Finished with lunch.
The food is kind of on the plainer side,
but it was, yeah, very
good, quality ingredients.
You could taste the
freshness of the ingredients.
Actually, that was a very late
lunch because it's almost,
it's gonna be sunset pretty
soon so we gotta rush,
and it's about a 30-minute
drive to get to the sunset spot.
(ethereal contemporary music)
But have we gained quite
a lot of elevation.
But this place is called the Eagles Nest.
Oh, it's cold up here.
It's cold, Micah, are you cold?
So, we sorta missed the sunset because
it already has gone down below the peak
but the view is absolutely spectacular,
and you can see all the different
colors of purple and blue.
There's so much snow on those peaks,
and then down here, this
is the main Hunza Valley
where the Karimabad,
where we were staying,
and I believe that's what
they call Ladyfinger.
That's such a jagged, sharp peak.
(ethereal contemporary music)
The actual sun is shining
onto these peaks over here.
They're monstrous, and then so much snow.
You're starting to see more colors.
Yeah, we gained some elevation.
I can feel that.
Yeah, it's chilly up here too.
- I was thinking about it over there,
like, if you could ever say
that something could top this,
you'd have to, like, leave the earth.
- [Mark] Otherworldly.
- Yes.
- Okay, I think we're getting out of here.
It is freezing cold, but it's a truly
an epic viewpoint, just 360 all around.
It's mind blowing.
(ethereal contemporary music)
For dinner tonight, we've been invited
by a local family to eat
at their home arranged
by the minister of tourism GB,
so we're just on our way there now.
Okay, so we've met up with our host,
and he's taking us down.
This is a very unique area
of town, watery streets,
and we're also very close
to the Altit Fort, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay, thank you,
and this is where your home is?
- [Guide] Yeah, of course.
- [Mark] Wow, very cool.
- Yeah, most of the
houses are built of stone.
(Pakistani instrumental music)
- It's so cool walking
back in these streets.
I mean, you can really walk back
into some really narrow, narrow lanes.
You can see the walls made of
stone and mud construction,
and I think we arrived at the house.
Thank you.
- [Guide] Okay, so this was
in the border of the house
so it came just--
- [Mark] Wow.
- Karimalhan Hasaramom, he had
visited this house specially.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
- [Mark] Nice to meet you.
Thank you.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Very cool, very cozy on the
inside of this carpeted,
and with pads on the floor,
and then this is within
one of the stone homes.
It's beautiful, and this is amazing.
(clapping)
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
(applause)
And this house has a lot of historical
important significance as well.
It's like a museum of a home because
it's so well preserved, and so ancient.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
The first course which is the soup.
DaoDao, DaoDao, it's called DaoDao.
I have the extreme honor
of sitting next to Grandma
who is an amazing lady.
This is her house.
She's welcomed us into her house,
and this looks like a hearty soup.
You can see those
dough-like, pieces of dough
which are in the soup.
It looks almost like a
porridge because it's so thick.
(speaking foreign language)
- 85.
- Wow, she's 85-years old.
She's beautiful.
She's absolutely beautiful.
Oh, that's amazing.
It's really hardy and warm,
and compared to other versions we had,
this has more of the noodles
in it, so it's more hardy.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Okay, again, I think I said
this earlier today, but this is
the soup that you want to be
eating when it's cold outside.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Okay, they're just bringing
out more and more dishes,
but all local Hunza dishes.
This one's very interesting.
It's potato with apricot seed paste.
And he just brought out
an apricot seed chapati,
so inside is an apricot taste
but I think it's apricot seed,
which is almost like almond.
That almost tastes like a
spring onion, like cream cheese
but then it's like nutty.
Wow.
That's like refreshing and kind of oniony.
All right.
I'm gonna try the rose
dumpling next and, yeah, it's
wrapped up but filled with yak meat,
and then there's a sauce.
Yeah, that's like a giant dumpling.
I think it is a one biter.
Yeah, that's a big bite though.
It's like right at that
stage where you're not sure.
And that tastes like a sweet,
kind of like apricot sauce.
Okay, next up, I'm
gonna try the pasta dish
which is made from wheat.
Look like little sheets, and then shaved,
and then cooked up with a vegetable.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Oh, it has like this
wonderful sourness to it,
and then you can taste the
herbs, a slight bitter vegetable.
This one is the potato with
the apricot seed paste.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Oh wow.
That's like the greatest mashed potatoes
you've ever had in your life.
It's so natural tasting, and
then the potatoes just dissolve
in your mouth, and just
so nutritious tasting.
Okay, next up for the
Chapshoro, and this is something
we've had already a couple of times today,
but this is really one of
the local staple foods.
This one is loaded with yak meat.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
You can taste the onions in there,
and they're just wrapped
up in that mince meat.
Yeah, and that one has a
little more spice to it.
(speaking foreign language)
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Okay, one more dish that I didn't try yet
filled with cheese on
the inside, and kind of,
again, the thin layers of dough.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Oh, that's like a really kind
of sour, like, cream cheese
kind of sensation, fully organic,
just creme Hunza Valley,
everything we're eating.
In the Hunza Valley, they are
known for being very healthy,
and many old people, and many,
a very high life expectancy,
because of the fresh air,
and especially because of the food.
And so one of the very traditional dishes
that we've been eating and, actually,
it's probably my favorite
dish of the entire meal,
is the chapati which is filled
with the apricot seed paste,
as well as walnuts, and I
think there's some apricot oil
as well, and that it one of the dishes,
that is one of the traditional
foods of the Hunza Valley
that is credited with longevity
and the health, the good health.
Oh, the mint in that bite.
Yeah, that's one of the best dishes.
What is that, Mr. Ali?
- I'm holding that secret for you.
The real secret of longevity.
- [Mark] Desserts.
- This one bite gonna add one more year.
One bite adds one more year.
Wow, amazing.
- Wow.
Oh, the honey, it tastes like
caramelized honey in there.
And then you got that tart, cherry jam.
Wow, that's like a juicy,
honey-filled pancake.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
That was an unbelievable
experience, with the music,
the food, the family,
having the honor to sit next
to Grandma as she just smiled,
and then just that food.
Watch your step.
Oh, we just figured out
that this is a 400-year,
they mentioned this a 400-year old house.
Wow, yeah, that was so cool.
- What a treat.
- Yeah, a privilege.
- A real treat, yeah.
- [Man] Mind your head, Sir.
- [Mark] Okay, thank you.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
Cat.
Thank you very much.
- [Man] This is traditions.
- Okay, thank you.
- [Man] Traditions.
Thank you.
(room chattering)
- [Man] Please, please.
- Shalom, welcome.
Shalom, welcome.
- Wasn't even sure what we were
gonna do, but we drove over,
and we were invited to
another house, another home.
This is really old, ancient
home, another stone home,
and we're all huddled around,
and they're sitting by the fire,
and I think they're preparing
something to eat again.
Wow, this is spectacular,
and what a warm welcome they gave us.
There's a big ...
(speaking foreign language)
(room chattering)
I'm not totally sure what
they're gonna make yet.
(speaking foreign language)
He's 86-years old, and he was in the army.
He has all these medals on his jacket,
and then this uncle is 72-years old,
72-years old.
It's such an unbelievable,
cultural learning experience.
(speaking foreign language)
(room chattering)
(food sizzling)
(utensils clattering)
(upbeat Pakistani music)
First they made this like flat
roti and then, after that,
they made pancakes so
that you get this batter
which she swirled onto the
hot plate, and then swirled
into a pancake shape, and
then flipped it, and then
it just sizzled, and
just bubbled away again.
We've got chai.
We've got a plate of grapes.
We've got the pancake, a Hunza pancake,
so you almost cannot explain
this entire situation,
and experience, and
cultural beauty in words.
Okay, but let's test the pancake.
You can really taste that butter
which is just fresh butter.
That tastes really good,
and then the pancake, yeah,
it has a wonderful kind of
gummy, spongy texture to it.
Home cooked, yeah, it's wonderful.
Oh yeah, I'm toasty warm,
actually, almost sweating
right now because I'm sitting
by the fire drinking tea,
but it feels so good.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
And they're seedless.
Oh man, just like perfectly sour and tart,
and juicy, and the seedless is great.
Then, immediately chase
that with some of the chai.
Thank you very much.
(speaking foreign language)
Thank you, I can get it.
- [Man] Okay, no problem.
- Thank you very much.
This is just kind of the entrance area,
entrance area of the house.
Okay, so we're heading
out of the house now but,
yeah, it was just an honor
to sit with the family.
Every generation was present,
and just to eat the pancakes,
to drink tea, everything
cooked fresh before us.
It was spectacular and special.
Yeah, it was an honor to
have that opportunity.
(rhythmic Pakistani music)
Thank you.
From the outside, it just
looks so dark and quiet,
but then you step inside,
and there's like 20 people,
all family, inside.
It's so cozy and warm too.
Wow.
That was amazing.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you very much.
- You too.
- Nice to meet you.
(upbeat Pakistani music)
Bye-bye, nice to meet you.
Okay, made it back to the hotel.
It is a chilly evening.
Massive thank you to Suleiman,
who is the director of tourism
in GB, Gilgit-Baltistan,
for arranging that for us,
and for Ali from Landmark
Communications and Travels
for arranging everything this entire trip.
Okay, so that's gonna
be it for this video.
Thank you very much for watching.
Tomorrow, we have another
early, and a long day.
We're going up to the Kunjerab Pass.
We're also gonna have some local food.
Yeah, that's coming up in the next video,
but thank you for watching this video.
Please remember to give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it.
Leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you,
and if you're not already
subscribed, click subscribe now,
and also click the little bell icon
so that you get notified of
the next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching.
Goodnight from the Hunza
Valley in Pakistan.
See you on the next video.